los organismos internacionales no cesan
en su alerta sobre la situación de los
civiles en el conflicto en ucrania
quiero comenzar haciendo un llamado
sincero la humanidad en ucrania hoy
estamos viendo situaciones profundamente
angustiosas y de estrés inspirations la
situación se hace especialmente dura en
la ciudad de mariupol el comité
internacional de la cruz roja alerta que
se han acabado las reservas de ayuda
humanitaria en la ciudad y han
denunciado la situación atroz que viven
los civiles sin alimentos agua potable o
suministros médicos por moho la
conclusión de hoy es que la situación es
realmente apocalíptica para las personas
y está empeorando se están quedando sin
suministros esenciales o software en
estos ciudadanos ucranianos evacuados a
la autoproclamada república de don y ex
cerca mariupol así lo confirman
no había pan estaban vendiendo pan por
diez dólares ni agua ni gas
[Música]
la gente sobrevive como puede
en otras ciudades del país menos
nombradas en esta guerra la situación
también empeora con los días en
vila-seca a 75 kilómetros al sur de kiev
los estragos del conflicto se hacen ver
en las ruinas que dejan los bombardeos y
en supermercados con cada vez menos
productos diarios y
suministros pero no hay productos
lácteos por ejemplo y tenemos un niño
pequeño que los necesita
entretanto ciudadanos ucranianos
especialmente mujeres y niños siguen
huyendo de la guerra según la onu son ya
más de dos millones la mayoría huyen
hacia países vecinos de la unión europea
pero no todos se quedan allí en bruselas
las autoridades afirman que su oficina
de extranjería está desbordada por
personas en busca de una nueva vida
lejos de ucrania